millions of people in Shanghai counted
down to midnight on Wednesday
celebrating the end of a strict
two-month pandemic lockdown
there were scenes of joy and excitement
as people socialized outdoors and drove
their cars for the first time in weeks
Street barricades have been removed
supermarkets restaurants and parks are
reopening public transport has resumed
China's biggest city and Commercial
Center is slowly coming back to life
after being shut down at the end of
March
more than 600 000 coronavirus infections
were recorded in what was the country's
worst outbreak since the pandemic began
artist Sunshine was visiting the city
and became stuck in his hotel an initial
five-day lockdown stretched to more than
60 days
he's relieved it's over but remains
distrustful of the government
order so they tell people only five days
so I think you're fine but you know the
government always lie two people
the more and more and the more longer
and the longer and the longer and no
ending no people when it's finished
there was widespread anger along with
confusion over food shortages and a lack
of access to Emergency Medical Care the
lockdown also crippled Supply chains and
slowed the economy property and Car
Sales the service sector and Retail
consumption all plummeted in April
analysts say recovery won't be quick or
easy after the initial phase there might
be more disappointments
um because the reality is the consumer
confidence is dampened a property Market
is still weak although the weakness in
other parts of the economy was still
there and not addressed and on top of
that income growth has slowed
significantly so after the lift of all
the restrictions I think there is a lot
of work has to to be done
Shanghai authorities say the city has
achieved a mile start in its battle
against the virus in a letter they
thanked residents for their patience and
apologized for the inconveniences caused
people in Shanghai may be celebrating
for now but the memory of this long
lockdown won't easily be forgotten
China's leaders refused to live with the
coronavirus and any new outbreak can
result in the lives of millions being
upended without notice
Katrina you Al Jazeera Beijing